what's wrong with you people for bad
guys this is what we do this is the deal
you're going somewhere very bad do
something don't get spilled so intense
please don't touch me please don't touch
as gangsta we're two passes to cover up
don't forget we're the bad guys you're
going somewhere very bad to do something
that gets killed it was that like a pep
talk
of the great shine this album come to us
I'm not hugging not hurt her Suicide
Squad ATPG 30
hey youtubers as you can see they've
been doing a lot of punch up on Suicide
Squad
I think that's Jeff Jon's influence so
let's break this down I'm really happy
they let Will Smith be funny in this
movie I think going into it the
assumption is is that he's gonna be
super hardcore cause he's playing dead
shot dead shot isn't a character that
tells a lot of jokes he's not like a
jokey person but he does have a really
good sense of humor so I think that's
what we're seeing here and like rick
flagg tried to hug him at the end yeah
it's really funny but that's what really
makes them feel like a group of
characters like they vacillate between
really hardcore really serious crazy and
earnest and like what we're seeing here
this hug moment these two hardcore dudes
just hugging each other for a second is
the most naked of emotions like some big
WTF happens they pull off a save and
rick flagg is just like come here bring
it in for a hug so on the flip side of
that could you just imagine what that
would have been like if it was Superman
hugging Batman
I feel like Batman would be the Deadshot
in that situation I'm not a hugger don't
don't no don't don't touch if you guys
haven't been reading the rebirth comics
that have been happening you need to
check them out in the flash rebirth
there's this really funny line where
Barry Allen sitting there listening to
Batman talk and you're just seeing how
he's thinking at a mile a minute and he
remembers why it's inappropriate to tell
a joke Superman told me once
there's no laughing in the Batcave which
is a good example of a Batman joke a
joke that lets him be really hardcore
and is really funny at the same time
another good example of that on the
Suicide Squad is katanas character she's
not a jokey character she doesn't tell a
lot of jokes but she does have a really
good sense of humor Harley Quinn sense
of humor is a little more complex like
she seems like she's really into
slapstick she just won't shut up just
goes on and on and on but the real fun
with her character is when she gets
serious usually that's when you know
shits up like it's the reverse of Batman
if Batman told you a joke you would
think something is very very wrong but
that's totally normal for Harley Quinn
so when she gets really serious that's
when you know [ __ ] is up but let me know
what kind of funny moments you want to
see from these characters really just
that huggy moment is gonna be great I
feel like that's gonna be a bigger
payoff than the Joker telling jokes
because you expect that I think one of
the funniest moments with Heath Ledger's
Joker was when he made the pencil
disappear want to see a magic trick just
because it was so WTF and unexpect
you're like oh my god he actually made
the pen
disappear Annie took care of that
mobster at the same time that is Joker
humor humor that makes you feel really
bad when you laugh at it but what it
feels like they've changed about the
movie is they just allowed some of the
characters to have more emotions because
typically when you see a really hardcore
dude in a movie like this they have like
two emotions hardcore and even more
hardcore and that just doesn't work in a
comic book movie even a darker one like
this but a whole bunch of stuff
happening this week if you haven't been
paying attention to e3 there hasn't been
a whole lot of DC Comics games coming
out there there's been a bunch of Marvel
stuff recently with Spider Man Marvel
games Studios is doubling down they're
going hardcore on awesome games
spider-man is just the first one that
they've announced with insomniac games
there is a return to Arkham game but
that's really just an HD remaster of all
the Arkham games I just did an injustice
to video so I'll put a link for that in
the description that's really like the
biggest DC game that's come along in the
last couple days but get hype I'll be
posting some Game of Thrones tomorrow I
have a Q&A video that I'm working on if
there's any other DC videos you guys
want me to do this week just let me know
in the comments there's a little bit of
arrow stuff they've been talking about
The Spectre might be coming to arrow but
that's only a rumor and I haven't really
looked into it yet so I can't say a
whole lot about it until I check it out
so maybe I'll do a video on that later
this week what you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for the
injustice 2 gameplay trailer and you can
click here to learn all about the new
spider-man game thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight